there was a tick tock that just went
viral of
of a young deluded white liberal woman
explaining
how everything is racist
including
including eating meat
how is eating meat racist i'll gladly
tell you
looks like we've got an oppressor on our
hands
so during slavery times
slaves did not get to eat the same
things as their masters they got the
scraps that no one wanted chitterlings
now that black people have overcome
slavery they developed a rich barbecue
culture to make up for all the meat
eating that they lost out on
so when you go to the store and you buy
a piece of meat as a white person you
are actively taking away a piece of meat
that could be being enjoyed by a
survivor of ancestral slavery
eating meat is not only racist but it's
also anti-semitic during the holocaust
jews did not get to eat meat in labor
camps they ate potato soup which would
spill on their bodies burning them and
giving them infections
now
do survivors eat a lot of meat brisket
just let them have that stop
appropriating
when i first saw this i will admit i
thought it was satire
i don't think it is satire i think this
girl is is being serious
and there are so many levels of comedy
here
the first one
obviously not everything is about race
not every but but except everything sort
of is about race i've said on this show
before racism
just means bad that they are synonyms in
modern culture when people say racist
all they mean is bad when people call
you a racist all they mean is
i do not like you you are a bad person
it can have nothing to do with race
because we have decided that that is the
only sin is racism more on that in one
minute first though i want to bring you
into my bed okay head on over right now
to helix sleep.com
knowles you go over there you take a
quiz it takes two minutes to complete it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you and you just you'll get to know what
it's like in that michael knowles
boudoir okay there's a lot of things to
keep us up these days a lot of crazy
stuff going on in the world when you
want to sleep very important to take
care of that sleep get that beauty rest
you've got to go check out helix don't
sleep in a mattress made for someone
else sleep in a mattress made for you it
takes two seconds to take that quiz you
figure out what kind of mattress you
should be matched with and then helix is
offering up to two hundred dollars off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at
helixsleep.com do not miss out on this
deal these guys have a 10-year warranty
you're gonna get to try it out for a
hundred nights you're not gonna need a
hundred nights you're gonna have one
night you're gonna say this is the
greatest mattress ever head on over get
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows helix sleep.com
knowles we don't even use the language
of sin anymore and i think a lot of that
is because
race is only skin deep and we live in
this world where we're so absorbed by
materialism that we've got to make
everything about matter and so you say
you're racist it just means you're bad
but then of course the next layer of
comedy here is the the woman is saying
things that traditionally would be
considered pretty racist
and she goes listen you insensitive meat
eaters
you're taking away some of that good old
ham hock and chitlins from those black
people you know black people
they just they sit around and they eat
their collard greens and bacon you know
they're sitting on the front stoop in
alabama somewhere eating corn pone and
you think hold on lady are you is this a
minstrel show what are you talking about
you know i think black black people eat
sushi too did you know that black people
go they can eat italian food too they're
people just like you and me they say
black people anytime you eat barbecue
which is that's what black people that's
black people food okay black people eat
their black people food and you white
people you can eat
i don't know umami or something i don't
what do white people eat you can eat
tofu salad and the black people and jews
are going to eat brisket and if you eat
brisket you are
basically a holocaust denier you're a
rate it's all about
it's all about race
it's an it's an extreme example but this
is the kind of thinking that you see
going on and it's because we've confused
ourselves and made every single thing in
the entire world about race which is
it's it's the thing in american politics
that you cannot touch there's only one
word that you can't say
you can go on tv you can say the f word
you can say s-s-h-i-t
you can say the c-word
on tv okay i don't
because this is a wholesome family show
but you can do it people have said it on
tv there's one word you can't say
there's one word you can't even write
anymore what is that word it is the
n-word which is treated as more sacred
than the holy name of the lord by the
ancient israelites okay that's the word
because race
is the most taboo the most sacred issue
at all and so it's no surprise that we
make everything things that have nothing
to do with race become about race
[Music]